para empezar me gustaría invitarlos a
jugar siguiendo una consigna levanten
las manos lo que en este último tiempo
compró en una entrada para ir a ver un
show de lo que sea de música stand up
teatro levanten las manos voy a contar
un poco 1 2 5 6
23 aproximadamente contándome a mí muy
bien nos gusta el arte ahora les voy a
pedir que levanten la mano solo los que
compraron esa entrada para ir a ver un
show pero de música solo de música a ver
los musiqueros
tenga la mano arriba estos 15
22 sumándome a mí y ahora les pido que
solo dejen la mano arriba lo que
compraban esa entrada para ir a ver un
show de música de alguien no famoso de
alguien de los que llamamos no
reconocidos que no vemos en la tele ni
en la radio a ver
como bajaron esas manitos pero voy a
seguir contando hay tres cuatro cinco
seis siete ocho doce bien
le digo que bajaron las manos pero que
seguimos firme a los buenos ahí y ahora
les pido que levanten la mano y la
sostengan pero con mucho orgullo los que
compraron esa entrada para ver a alguien
hay un show de música no reconocido que
no sea familiar ni amigos
y no he comprado en una entrada para
conocer este nuevo artista pagaron un
derecho de espectáculo
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
sumándome a mi espectacular
esta cifra si ustedes ven que más o
menos somos 100 personas me deja un poco
pensando que sólo 7 hayamos quedado con
la mano arriba porque porque aquí en la
ciudad de funes y acá muy cerquita la
ciudad de rosario solo en los bares
culturales se realizan aproximadamente
1200 shows al año
qué les parece que solo nosotros hayamos
quedado con la mano arriba solo 7
esto que sucede aquí es un ejemplo de lo
que en realidad sucede en toda la
sociedad este tipo de acciones o mejor
dicho vamos a decir no acciones son las
que le dieron lugar en los años 60 al
movimiento under
qué es el movimiento under esto proviene
de la cultura underground que significa
subterráneo no se imaginen artistas
hippies zombies saliendo del subsuelo a
la ciudad no son simplemente aquellos
artistas que no están auspiciados por
las grandes productoras que explotan el
arte
alguno conoce algunos de esos artistas
que no están auspiciados por esas
grandes productoras que explotan el arte
vamos a pensar e imaginar para entender
aún mejor esta escena una pirámide
aquí en esta cúspide se encuentran los
que nosotros llamamos famosos los que
vemos en la tele la radio vemos en los
festivales en todos lados
como pueden observar esta cúspide es
bastante pequeña por lo cual entran sólo
algunos pocos y ahí vamos a descender
sin freno a la base de esta pirámide en
esta base se encuentran los artistas y
las bandas under como pueden ver esta
base es muchísimo más grande por lo cual
entran muchos más pero debajo de esta
base en el subsuelo de esta pirámide
estoy yo el under del under el subsuelo
del subsuelo pero porque les digo esto
porque no solo hace 24 años camino con
muchísimo esfuerzo el camino del under
musical sino que además decidí cantar
folklore
guau guau guau guau
si folklore estoy seguro que cuando se
los dije muchos se imaginaron que
estamos todos vestido de gaucho en un
patio de tierra comiendo empanadas con
la guita ya en una mano y la copa de
vino en la otra y si no tendría nada de
malo que fuese así pero sin embargo a la
sociedad eso le resulta un tanto bizarro
y antiguo de ahí descendemos
directamente al under del under del
under
pero también permítanme contarles que
los que nos dedicamos de forma
profesional a esto nos preocupamos por
hacerlo bien y nos profesionalizamos
estudiamos música estudiamos canto
también si nos gusta y tenemos la
oportunidad le sumamos el estudio de un
instrumento ensayamos a full lo que nos
permite por supuesto solo a través de
los años subir algunos escalones y hasta
podemos disfrutar y experimentar todos
los estilos musicales está buenísimo
esto no
pero aunque elegimos todos los días esto
que hacemos y lo amamos este camino no
es para nada color de rosa sin embargo
parece ser todo lo contrario que es
solamente para algunos pero porque les
digo esto
vamos a pensar juntos en alguien que
decide emprender su camino musical de
forma profesional a parte del bullying y
las negativas y que quiere ser hippie
toda la vida aparte de todo eso
necesita comenzar con una inversión
inicial como cualquier persona que
encara un proyecto tiene un
emprendimiento
quiero recalcar les que los montos que
les voy a compartir a continuación son
los más accesibles que podemos encontrar
en el mercado para emprender un camino
profesional
primero clases de música una vez a la
semana a una hora por clases necesitamos
contar como mínimo con 1500 pesos
mensuales lo que nos llevó en inversión
total anual de 18 mil pesos bueno
ahora pensemos en una sala de ensayo una
vez a la semana dos horas por ensayo
tiene un valor el alquiler de esa sala
de dos mil quinientos pesos mensuales lo
que nos llevaría a una inversión anual
de 30 mil pesos
hablemos de comprar un instrumento
obviamente que depende que el
instrumento sea de calidad de sonido
tiene de qué marca es este instrumento
pero vamos a partir de una base de 35
mil pesos ni hablar si decidiste ser
baterista nos arrancas con nada con 35
pero vamos a empezar con una base de
estas va sumando no es cierto
quiero decirles lo que cuesta grabar un
disco
esto de que los discos hoy no se
comercializan no importa porque la
grabación del material se realiza igual
tanto si lo grabó en un estudio como si
quiero ponerle la mejor de la onda y
hacerlo en casa estudiar un poco hacerme
algún curso comprarme lo básico necesito
comenzar con una inversión de 100 mil
pesos mínimo mínimo recontra mínimo
y si todavía somos re heavy si rejodido
y queremos hacer la presentación de este
material llevarlo a un show en un teatro
pequeño de 200 personas sentadas
necesitan necesitamos humana esta
inversión 20 mil pesos más sólo por el
alquiler del teatro
fueron haciendo la cuenta y por si
alguno se perdió vamos a hacer juntos un
cálculo rápido
grabación del disco preparación de un
año como mínimo aproximadamente hasta el
momento del show con todo lo que
mencionamos antes necesitamos una
inversión individual de 203 mil pesos
sin contar sin contar tiempo invertido
publicidad las redes que hoy es crucial
es lo que mueve todo diseño gráfico ropa
traslado comida si sos cantante y tenés
que aparte contratar músicos
se los dejo a su criterio
imagínense
lo que nos pasa a nosotros los músicos
cuando nos encontramos adelante de estos
números
la mayoría se frustra deja que
directamente sus sueños se vaya a un
cajón y se dedicó otra cosa estoy segura
que muchos de los que estamos acá
conocemos a alguien que hoy está sentado
atrás de un escritorio o está
dedicándose otra cosa por así decirlo
cuando realidad quiere estar acá arriba
arriba del escenario haciendo arte
lamentablemente parece ser que este tipo
de sueños es solo para eso justamente
para ser simplemente sueños porque
cumplirlos es solo para algunos pocos y
el solo hecho de intentarlo la verdad ya
vimos recién es muy pero muy costoso
ahora les voy a contar algo también en
los años 60
dijeron no un grupo de artistas dijo no
no puede ser que los sueños sean
solamente para algunos y crearon el
movimiento under movimiento al cual le
debemos varias subculturas musicales que
hoy las tenemos arraigadas como propias
por ejemplo el punk el grand el hardcore
el heavy metal el hip hop el reggaeton
entre otros de hecho aquí mismo en
argentina le debemos nuestro gran y
querido rock que es uno de los pilares y
estilos musicales más importantes de
nuestro país
en esa época en los 60 el under el
movimiento under buscaba a visibilizarse
y salir de los subterráneos pero hoy en
día hay muchas bandas under que por
supuesto no están auspiciados por las
grandes productoras pero que tampoco
quieren estarlo
y se preguntarán por qué no quieren
estarlo
y les cuento que no se trata de querer o
no querer ser famoso no hay nada en
contra de eso todo lo contrario
solamente queremos hacer nuestro arte
nuestra música la música que nosotros
elegimos el repertorio que elegimos el
estilo que regimos después de tanto
trabajo sin tener que seguir las reglas
de las grandes productoras que solo y
únicamente se rigen por lo que vende o
por lo que no vende esta no es nuestra
forma de llevar adelante nuestra
profesión y es por eso que llevamos con
tanto orgullo la bandera del under y
queremos contarle que se trata pero
quiero decirles que hay otro ejemplo que
nos puede ayudar a entender mejor un
ejemplo que solo que seguramente vamos a
conocer todos
hablando del indio solari y voy a dejar
de lado las preferencias musicales y las
opiniones personales para contarles que
si bien él comenzó arrancó su carrera
con una banda hiper conocida que es
los redonditos de ricota muy bien que
obviamente también pertenecieron a la
escena del under pero hoy el indio
solari es uno de los solistas referentes
de la cultura under porque junto con su
equipo se autogestiona de manera tal que
puede lograr grabar sus propios discos y
realizar sus propios shows
multitudinarios sin necesitar de las
grandes productoras es por eso que
rescatamos esto de la autogestión
hoy tenemos herramientas para hacer del
under un lugar mejor
de hecho la tecnología es un pilar para
eso porque nos permite obviamente con
una inversión nada se mueve sin plata
poder llegar a cualquier lugar del
planeta en cualquier momento a través de
la tecnología
vieron qué difícil es llevar adelante
una simple banda under
todo lo que conlleva la creación de un
disco el tiempo invertido los no que
recibimos las puertas cerradas la poca
aceptación del público de hecho aquí
mismo de 100 personas sólo siete
quedamos con la mano levantada recuerdan
y si después de todo esto después de
lograr grabar ese disco llegará el
momento cumbre de la realización del
show en el teatro recibimos mensajes
como los que les voy a mostrar ahora yo
no sé si reírnos y llorar pero quiero
ver qué dicen ustedes
lo que cantas deberías estar en la tele
gracias
gracias bravo
esto es así qué piensan ustedes
felicitaciones me sorprendió como
cantaste re bien les sorprendió porque
seguro estaba pensando está un bodrio
tengo que irme tengo que fumar todo el
yo pero después me escucho le gustó y se
sorprendió la chihuahuense marta
a ver este no me digas que cantaste pero
con una me avisaste avísame la próxima
no nada más lo puse en todas las redes
sociales
cadena de whatsapp de oración de todo
pero la próxima voy a ir hasta tu casa
te voy a ir a avisar pero te aseguro que
no vas a poder ir porque tienes que
cuidar a tu sobrino te cambio en el
turno del trabajo tuviste 45 de fiebre
no se pongan la excusa que más le guste
porque está le hicimos todo yo también
y ahora acompáñame a ver esta triste
historia
con la voz que tenés
debería tendrías que estar cantando otra
cosa que venda más
que fracasó ya imagínense que alguien le
hubiese dicho a cerati perdón salvando
las distancias porque no te cantas
presión americana en versión cumbia que
eso vende muchísimo más
por todas estas cosas y por muchas cosas
más estaría buenísimo comprender que la
escena del under vive solo y únicamente
a través del apoyo del público apoyo que
hace que la escena local multiplique sus
iniciativas convirtiendo las nuevas
propuestas artísticas los que nos
autogestionamos y autogestionamos
nuestra propia banda desearíamos
trabajar como una especie de cooperativa
en donde cantantes músicos managers
familia y si las familias desde la
preparación del sanguchito hasta el mate
y me detengo un segundo en las familias
como pilar porque las horas de ensayos
son larguísimas los toques los fines de
semana también y les aseguro que conozco
un montón de amigos músicos que tuvieron
que dejar de hacer lo que amaban porque
sus familias no pudieron o no supieron
cómo hacerle el aguante
acá tendríamos que repartir todo por
igual alegrías tristezas garrones peleas
hasta los frutos y las recompensas
decía frank zappa un gran artista y
compositor guitarrista reconocido que la
cultura oficial a esa la que ves en la
tele siempre sale a nuestro encuentro
querramos o no le agregó yo pero una
lander al under tenemos que ir nosotros
mismos
por eso les propongo una cosa vaya
compren se una entrada es a las que le
permite estar ahí cerquita de ese
artista escucharlo felicitarlos sacarte
una foto con él o con ella preguntarle
qué quiso decir en esa parte del tema
que tanto te gustó o a quien se lo
dedico y ahí sí sólo ahí vamos a poder
decir mañana y con orgullo yo yo lo
conozco desde que arrancó muchas gracias
[Aplausos]